let's see let's go on to the uh second
or last one I think yeah second to last
award this one is you know obviously we
didn't have as many After Dark episodes
this year yeah but we still had enough
to be able to do this category yeah we'd
like to know what you guys thought was
the strongest episode so this next award
is the best trash taste after dark
episode or moment over this episode here
so this is the best trash taste after
dark moment all right let's go through
all right uh the boys handling animals
in Australia my favorite one of that is
when I think what was it it was the baby
crocodile or like the uh the lizard or
something was just freaking out in your
hand yeah they did not like being in my
hand no that was such a good episode
though I remember this this screenshot
of me just petting that lizard you'll
spread around on the Reddit to be like
yes we will take over the world don't
worry
uh we got everyone not getting the Among
Us sounds in the gamer quiz yeah that
hurts I think the one that go clipped a
lot was uh all three of us going it's so
weird you mentioned that earlier yeah
God accidentally opens up a cultured
book oh yeah oh I have to stop you from
showing that on the stream
uh we got gone spending ten dollars
instead of a hundred dollars on the
Christmas special this was uh I feel
like this was a personal favorite of
mine because uh the last Challenge on
the uh Christmas special I feel like
epitomizes trash taste in a nutshell so
we we had a challenge to buy presents
for each other yeah and we had a hundred
dollars to buy presents for each other
and uh we all did uh something different
for this challenge because Joey followed
the rules I mistakenly
um mistook a hundred dollars for ten
dollars
and Connor uh completely forgot about
this Challenge and just brought [__]
from his house
which I feel epitomizes each of our
personalities
I give you guys again I don't even
[__] remember I probably threw it out
I gave you a kiddie pool yeah you gave
me a kitty pool which I took back what
did you give me I don't remember what I
gave you I don't know
yeah and then uh the last one is
everyone gets drunk in the wine stream
that was my favorite after dark stream
oh yeah that was the one where the uh
John Perry III and the stream [__]
destroying itself even like everyone got
drunk including the sets
crazy Jesus Christ yeah great episode
but they can only be one winner what was
the best moment of the after dark
episode
voted by you at home and the winner is
drum roll please
everyone gets drunk in the wine
yeah that was my favorite I do think
that was a very very good episode just
involved alcohol uh and going on live
faces just being smug and beating Sydney
it was just such a good combination of
it was just great it was I'm so happy it
was like drunk energy as well
they they got a they got a screenshot
all right yeah
what was the top three yeah everyone
gets drunk in the wine through 18.2 oh
it's actually quite close that's very
close Okay in second place the boys
handling animals in Australia oh that
was a very funny yeah
well glad to know you enjoyed those
moments but we have one award left isn't
that right gone yes we have one final
award which is the best trash taste
episode of the Year God how do you
decide yeah I don't know
um I mean the hardest part uh of this is
that I can barely remember all the
episodes of the year so I don't know how
you guys ended up voting on it
yourselves uh but there were a lot of
memorable episodes this year a lot of
different guest episodes that were very
very memorable which is why we decided
to include it this year
um and uh yeah should we get to the
nomination let's find out best trash
taste episodes this year so we have
episode 120 Nile red episode 111 Pro ZD
episode 137 Pete episode 123 shower
thoughts which is the first non-guest
episode episode 124 Paul Felix episode
127 Charlie episode 145 Hassan episode
114 Ludwig episode 101 Emily that was
the first of this year uh the second
hand type so 144 the road trip special
and our boy got married episode 107. so
it's kind of all over the board yeah
wholesome episodes a lot of guest
episodes obviously because they're very
diverse but uh some good triple trash
taste ones in there yeah I mean I I
personally just want to give it to
the special but like I don't know uh
yeah it's kind of tough really I mean
all of these I wouldn't be mad yeah yeah
all of them I had a lot of fun filming
that's why they got nominated uh
I feel the road trip special turned out
pretty well as well uh but it took so
much [__] time and effort
um
that we only ended up releasing one
special this year right yeah I don't
think so yeah only one special which we
said we're gonna do more and we didn't
yeah so sorry
honestly yeah I'm okay with any of these
winning they're all [__] amazing
episodes
um
you know
lots of things yeah I don't know which
one really to win it's it's all good
memories uh but there can only be one
winner for what you guys voted as the
best episode this year to cap off to cap
off this third year of trash taste all
right here we go which is why the winner
for the best trash taste episode in I
guess season three yeah season three of
trash taste is
it's just a testament to Pete's
character and being able to tell a story
that's engaging yeah a lot of people
weren't familiar with Pete when they
went into the episode yeah and I think
they left feeling really engaged and
really fascinated by uh a very talented
Storyteller yeah I mean I think quality
speaks for itself because when we first
release the episode uh going into like
the analytics the Pete episode performed
pretty like average or even like maybe
below average just because a lot of
people didn't know P back then yeah and
uh it's soon over time turned out to be
one of the most successful episodes I
think it's got over two million views
now wow yeah yeah yeah which is just
crazy which is just a testament to the
quality of the episode itself so
congratulations congratulations
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah and uh thank you guys for
tuning in to the annual trash taste
Awards um and thank you for another
[__] amazing year of trash day yeah
it's been a great year the fact that
we're able to do this for 150 episodes
and you guys are still loving it still
coming back every week it makes us just
super [__] happy yeah so we
appreciate you guys so much and uh on to
season four right into season four yeah
I think the big thing this year I will
always remember is this is the year that
we got to like interact with you guys
for the first time after just being
through a screen and just seeing
comments and seeing the Reddit post this
was the year that we actually got to
meet you guys shake you guys hand put
maybe even perform in front of you guys
uh and it was a [__] incredible
feeling and we hope to do more exciting
things in the coming year some of which
we've already announced the tour yeah we
are very excited to go meet our Euro
Bros keep your eyes out on that guy and
uh I know we talk about this every year
but specials but we've we actually have
already some in the backlog so yeah do
not worry about that uh with that there
will definitely be more specials this
year yeah I mean I think for us it was
the specials we're just trying to get a
better way of making them because right
now although all the other specials just
us making them yeah and the problem is
is that we'll do our own things yeah we
also struggle to just keep up with trash
taste in general yeah so you know we're
trying to we're trying to try some new
stuff out maybe bring more people on
board to try and help the process so we
want to get to the point where trashy
specials are more frequent and hopefully
higher quality yeah uh so we're working
on that uh it's we're not just doing
nothing stuff is coming yeah and of
course it's all a big uh thanks to you
guys who support us on the patreon as
well guys if you guys weren't supporting
us ever on the patreon over there we
wouldn't be able to do half the things
that we do so we super [__]
appreciate you guys for sticking to the
patreon